flaming tires and other debris burned in
Porter Prince hades's embattled Capital
as residents protested against
overwhelming gang violence many here say
life has become
unbearable I'm on the street today
because my area of perer is not good I
can't stay at home there are a lot of
explosions at the moment people are
leaving their houses I have found myself
obliged to take to the streets to say no
to
Ariel Ariel ref ERS to prime minister
Ariel HRI who has held office without
elections since the assassination of
President jenel Moise in July
2021 many Haitians consider HRI an
illegitimate
ruler the entire Republic must rise to
make Ariel HRI respond we can no longer
stand the insecurity nothing is
functional not even the Democratic
institutions we want elections free of
gangs the head of state is now even
involved in gangs the whole country is
gangsterz gangs now control an estimated
80% of Porto Prince and vast swaths of
the
countryside gang killings doubled last
year to 4500 and kidnappings surged by
80% gang members also engage in
widespread rape and sexual assault of
women and girls Nel vme was injured in a
shootout in his neighborhood of
solino on Sunday I was sitting with a
friend near my house when three bullets
came in one hit me and broke the bone
but I don't have the means to go to the
hospital according to the UN agency
UNICEF more than 300,000 Haitians have
fled their homes because of violence and
insecurity I ran I have children with me
I ran with them I have nothing for them
they kill people they chase us that's
why I left the
area last year the United Nations came
up with a plan to bring several thousand
police officers from Kenya to help
stabilize Haiti but a Kenyan Court
blocked the deployment ruling that it
was
unconstitutional for now Haitians say
they can't see a way out Rob Reynolds Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer